bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78
édition spéciale du 7-8 jusqu'au 1er
janvier la rédaction revient sur les
événements qui ont marqué dès 2012 est
également sur ceux qui vont rythmer
l'année 2013 cinq émissions à découvrir
pour cinq thématiques politiques
environnement économie culture est ce
soir du sport bonsoir et énergisant soir
où ils frisent est avec vous que nous
allons parler sport ce soir et nous
aurons deux invités pour nous
accompagner au cours de la prochaine
demi heure nous recevrons philippe
pilato le directeur de l'enseignement du
golf national nous évoquerons avec lui
la ryder cup que le golf de saint
quentin en yvelines a eu en pour 2018 et
l'open traditionnel open national qui se
déroulera en juillet prochain et en
deuxième invité yves macheboeuf le
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge des
grands projets commanditaires et pilote
du projet sportif du vélodrome le futur
son entraînement du cyclisme français
ils mâchent boeuf qui est déjà avec nous
ce soir bonsoir à vous bonsoir bonsoir
et avant justement de parler de ce
vélodrome nous allons revivre les
performances que vous avez forcément
suivi des athlètes yvelinois c'était
lors des jeux olympiques de londres oui
comment ne pas penser à nous à tête
olympique une année d'un de jeux
olympiques cet été on sportif yves
binois étaient présents à londres trois
sont revenus avec une médaille accrochée
autour du cou quelques semaines après
leur performance ils étaient reçus par
le président de la république à l'elysée
pour la première fois athlètes
paralympiques et olympiques réunis une
un sujet réalisé avec patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est en quelque sorte leurs récompenses
a eu la photo de famille avec le
président de la république ou le métal
olympique brille de tout son éclat
athlètes valides et handisports ils ont
tous porté haut les couleurs de la
france aux jeux de londres les
représentants il dit noyon décroché
quatre médailles il ne voulait pas
manquer ce rendez vous à l'elysée oui
forcément très important l'elysée c'est
quelque chose de tout nouveau pour moi
c'était la première fois que je venais
donc c'est vrai convient bas reviennent
dans un premier temps en temps curieux
et puis on vient dans un deuxième temps
en tant qu'athlète pour pour être
récompensé par le un discours de
monsieur françois hollande donc ça c'est
toujours quelque chose de très très
émouvant et j'en profite au maximum et
le plus souvent la médaille est apportée
d'objectifs je peux vous la montrer elle
est là
donc voilà vous avez la médaille
d'argent des jeux paralympiques de
londres elle est pas loin parce qu'on me
la demande régulièrement je fais quand
même pas mal de photos avec beaucoup de
gens qui veulent partager des moments
avec cette médaille je pense que c'est
quand même un objet qui est très
précieux pour moi et qui le reste tombe
tout au long de ma vie après une
compétition aussi unique que les je
viens souvent le temps de la remise en
question continuer ou pas de vivre pour
sa passion pour l'instant je savoure
savoir tout ce qui se passe là tout ce
qui m'arrive je vis pleinement le moment
je me pose ensuite je réfléchis je
prends une décision ferme et définitive
avant les jeux c'était prévu l'arrêt
bien sûr ce que je m'étais engagé à
faire et aujourd'hui je réfléchis mais
c'est normal après un tel événement on a
besoin de se poser un peu
je sais pas répondre à la question
aujourd'hui je encore une fois j'ai
besoin d'un temps de réflexion
une ou deux photos souvenirs avant de
repartir à l'entraînement avec pour
certains rio 2016 dans un petit coin de
la tête on parlait donc de londres 2012
et il aurait pu s'agir de paris 2012 les
deux communes les deux villes étaient
candidates toutes les deux les deux pays
étaient candidats pour obtenir ces jeux
olympiques on va en parler un petit peu
tout de même de paris 2012 le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est le
dernier vestige un petit peu de ce
dossier de candidature du projet paris
2012 qui avait été développée donc vous
le savez à l'occasion de la candidature
française il aurait pu ne jamais voir le
jour finalement les élus que ce soit
locaux au niveau national ont réussi à
obtenir ce vélodrome l'image meuf vous
supervisez justement pour
l'agglomération ce chantier comment se
passe le chantier tout d'abord est ce
qu'on est dans les temps écoutez si ça
avait été pour 2012 ça aurait été
compliqué mais à partir du moment où on
a pris comme objectif que ce vélodrome
sorte les délais étaient moins la
contrainte s'il y avait eu olympique
aujourd'hui on est dans les temps on est
dans le cadre du contrat
je pense que tous les saint quentinois
peuvent voir maintenant ce bâtiment
sortir de terre on a eu l'occasion de
faire des visites aujourd'hui
je dirais on est à la phase
du toit avec les premières parties qui
vont permettre aux bâtiments des torts
dos tout ça ça devrait au retour en
février ce qui va permettre à près de
pouvoir réaliser l'aménagement intérieur
et on aura pour la fin 2013
ce beau bateau ce beau joyau à la
disposition naturellement de nos
athlètes au niveau national mais surtout
au niveau local pour le sport mais aussi
la culture et nos entreprises on parlait
juste tout à l'heure donc de londres
2012 des médaillés et binoy qui sont qui
sont revenus est tout de même ce petit
regret de ne pas avoir eu cette
candidature voir aboutir finalement
c'est pas un petit regret c'est un grand
regret voilà
piloter je dirais avec eux seront élus
et dont le président de l'agglomération
la candidature sur sur saint quentin la
déception a été immense lorsque on a vu
douze échappés
cette candidature j'ai eu l'occasion de
me rendre à londres là cet été
je peux vous dire que les jeux
olympiques c'est un super challenge
d'abord un clin d'oeil quand même à nos
amis anglais parce que ils ont récupéré
les jeux mais ils ont été à la hauteur
et il faut le reconnaître j'ai été
extrêmement surpris de l'organisation en
tout cas fair play off est clair je veux
dire aujourd'hui je pense qu'en france
on aurait été capable de faire la même
chose mais ils ont il n'y a pas de faux
pas enfin les choix qu'ils ont faits et
des contestable sur le positionnement
des équipements mais je dirais à
l'arrivée le fonctionnement la mise en
oeuvre l'ambiance et puis nos athlètes
magnifique qui veut dire honnêtement
j'en ai croisé quelques simples france
agen grand coup de chapeau qu'il soit
l'illinois où qu'ils soient du reste du
territoire non franchement quelle belle
fête on revient à ce vélodrome on va
rester à saint quentin en yvelines un
petit rappel le lancement officiel de ce
projet c'était le 19 octobre 2009 venu à
l'hôtel d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'époque à
montigny le bretonneux en présence de
rama yade la secrétaire d'état aux
sports du maire de montigny et robert
cadalbert vous l'avez également à
rappeler et finalement le vélodrome qui
va voir le jour en 2013 oui fin 2013
indécent 2013 si si on est bien dans les
temps pour accueillir peut-être cette
première compétition dont tout le monde
parle ces championnats de france début
2014 janvier février 2014 se seraient
déjà en fin de compte un peu
l'inauguration vrai elle au niveau
sportif du vélodrome
tout à fait il faut bien débuter à
moment départ une manifestation c'est
vrai que le vélodrome devraient être
livrés fin d'année il a besoin de se
roder février mars devrait être
le premier vraiment coup d'envoi sur la
partie vélo
on est candidats aujourd'hui pour ces
championnats de france
en sachant qu'on aura dans les villes du
temps à passer la vitesse supérieure que
ce soit au niveau européen au niveau
mondial et puis ce vélodrome hausse en
son sein il y aura une piste
exceptionnels de 250 mètres de long avec
un espace bmx couvert unique en europe
ça sera aussi le gros gros atout de ce
complexe à saint quentin en yvelines
alors bien sûr c'est une piste olympique
mais là une spécificité cette piste
parce que ça serait une piste à record
puisqu'elle est plus large que la
plupart des pistes ça veut dire qu'on
peut monter plus haut dans les virages
ça veut dire qu'on peut sur beaucoup de
records améliorer les choses donc nous
avons avec impatience l'utilisation par
les sportives de cette piste et puis
cette piste de bmx qui arrive à un
moment donné où nos champions en ont
vraiment besoin bien sûr là une
spécificité c'est sa couverture ça veut
dire que nos champions pourront
s'entraîner
toute l'année la différence aujourd'hui
des pistes bmx qui sont des qui fait
mauvais temps un peu plus compliqué à
utiliser elles sont pas utilisables mais
c'est plus facile d'avoir une piste
couverte elle va répondre à mon avis a
besoin pour permettre à nos athlètes
d'atteindre des sommets et justement ce
complexe qui est en construction ce
vélodrome plus la piste de bmx certains
champions français l'ont déjà visité oui
grégory baugé notamment les membres de
l'équipe de france en octobre dernier
ont pu enfin découvrir pour la première
fois l'avancée des travaux de leur
nouveau centre d'entraînement leur
nouvelle maison un peu leur
clairefontaine à eux et nous avions
suivi cette visite avec elodie moines
un an après le lancement des travaux du
vélodrome dirigeants et membres de
l'équipe de france rendez visite ce
mardi alors futur quartier
d'entraînement à 50 ans on ignore
comment démêler l'écheveau tard que
jamais
après vélodrome dans la région que c'est
bien il y en aura d'autres en plus il ya
quelques mois ce qui séduit
et le chantier dans les temps les
tribunes qui entoureront la piste avec
une capacité de 5000 places sont déjà
construites au delà du vélodrome c'est
un vrai clairefontaine du vélo qui va
poser ses braqué à saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un vrai centre national
du cyclisme au delà même de date être un
vélodrome avec le siège de la fédération
ici on ça vivre à vélo ça va respirer
vélo et les administratives les
personnels vont pouvoir côtoyer les
sportifs ayora duras les vététistes les
dames
et les pilotes de bmx les pistards la
piste du vélodrome sera unique de par la
qualité de son bois sélectionnés en
sibérie mais aussi par son architecture
qui favorisera les performances des
pistards 250 mètres de long sur 8 mètres
de large des dimensions pensée pour
faire tomber les records
l'ouverture du vélodrome est prévue pour
décembre 2013 avec de possibles au
championnat de france dès 2014 mais en
attendant la visite s'est achevée par la
soirée des champions l'occasion de
rendre hommage aux médaillés olympiques
mais aussi aux jeunes espoirs qui
connaît
alors ce complexe exceptionnel va
sûrement impulser une dynamique
importante dans la région sur la
communauté d'agglomération avec
peut-être de nouveaux clubs de cyclisme
qui vont se créer dans les prochains
mois alors d'abord il est évident que
cet équipement est d'abord et avant tout
un équipement pour permettre à d'autres
élites de progresser mais sané puis ils
disent que le tiers du temps
des autres tiers ça sera réservé
naturellement les activités d'ordre
régional et local
j'espère que d'abord les clubs existants
vont pouvoir l'approprier cet équipement
mais que ça fera naître je dirais
d'autres dynamiques en tout cas les
crains hélas on vient de terminer avec
la fédération française de cyclisme et
puis le consortium qui gère le vélodrome
le polisson vient de terminer je dirai
des conventions de gestion parce que si
la construction l est les bons mois
bouclé on est dans la préparation de la
gestion et on va rentrer dans le vif du
sujet pour préparer les années à venir
pour permettre une appropriation cet
équipement a à notre territoire là juste
pour conclure sur ce vélodrome yves
macheboeuf à un sujet qui va peut être
fâché tout de même le vélodrome ne fait
pas toujours l'unanimité et un collectif
qui s'est monté vélodrome pour jouer sur
ce mode de vélodrome qui milite
notamment contre l'aspect du montage
financier qui est mélange publics et
privés puisque c'est comme ça que le
vélodrome va pouvoir voir le jour et
puis également l'aspect environnement
aussi écologique qui est contesté quelle
réponse vous pouvez leur apporter il ya
eu une forte contestation des pros c'est
aussi
moi j'ai aucun souci sur ce dossier je
crois que pour l'avoir manager depuis le
début sur l'aspect environnemental
il est aujourd'hui cité en exemple alors
de ce côté là je pense que si tous les
projets en france pouvait avoir le même
niveau je dirais traitement
environnementale sur l'ensemble de je
dirais de l'impact ça serait bien sûr le
montage de choix il habitait en dans un
travail collectif plusieurs types de
montages était possible là on est
vraiment dans une démarche où le ppc
imposait partenariat public le le choix
du ppp sur d'autres équipements envoyés
plus contestable sur la faculté moins
évident par contre sur la faculté
médecine par contre sur le vélodrome
c'est un équipement qui doit être
construit mais très tôt je vais aussi
gérer ce n'est pas à la collectivité de
gérer ce type d'équipement dont on est
vraiment dans une démarche de ce ppp ou
celui qui va être amené à gérer votre
est aussi amené à construire donc il a
intérêt à ce que l'équipement soit le
plus performant possible et en plus
davantage la ppp mais sûr qu'il faut le
suivre au niveau des élus c'est ce qu'on
fait mais les avantages qu'il ya c'est
qu'on a une vision globale de tous les
frais compris je dirais la gestion au
quotidien pendant les trente ans et ça
ça vous donne une maîtrise beaucoup plus
forte en fin de compte de ce que ça peut
coûter à la collectivité après chacun a
sa vision sur les ppp moi j'étais pas
forcément emballé au départ aujourd'hui
à avoir ça ne risque pas à long terme
d'avoir une incidence sur le budget de
fonctionnement
et le cadre de ppp c'est bien précis ça
donne les coups de 2 qui année après
année et après derrière la dynamique
globale du territoire la dynamique du
vélodrome permettra après derrière
d'amortir à part une partie des coûts ça
c'est évident non aujourd'hui le cadre
il est posé aujourd'hui quand on fait
des d'impact et que on rentre dans le
détail j'ai pas de souci de ce côté là
on est dans un territoire aujourd'hui de
la région parisienne on sait que sur la
dynamique de gestion de cet équipement
tant sur l'aspect économique et sur
l'aspect culturel que sportif
le vélodrome sera rempli merci yves
macheboeuf d'être venu donc sur ce
plateau nous parler du vélodrome qui
ouvrira donc ses portes en 2013 anthony
on continue cette édition spéciale du
7-8 de fin d'année à l'occasion des
fêtes de fin d'année pour parler d'un
autre événement sportif qui a remarqué
2012 oui les chirurgiens l'air libre
mais soul où il s'est révélé être un à
vingt mètres de l'apnée je veux bien sûr
parler de xavier delpy l'excellent dans
ce monde méconnu champion de france en
juin 2012 il a été sacré champion
d'europe et désormais co détenteur du
record du monde john blue nous allons
nous l'avions suivi lors de sa
préparation pour ces championnats
d'europe avec guillaume comps vous allez
découvrir ou redécouvrir un monde
fascinant
bienvenue dans le monde du silence
conduit les tel un poisson le rêve de
beaucoup le quotidien des apnéistes
alors on l'appelait je crois que j'ai
découvert comme un peu tout les gens à
peu près dans la tranche d'âge par le
grand bleu avec des magnifiques images
du grand bleu partout des dauphins le
plomb tombe amoureux xavier delpy a
découvert l'apnée il y a deux ans et
demi un peu par hasard lors d'une sortie
dans la mer rouge avec les dauphins
depuis ce chirurgien de 35 ans passe son
temps libre sous l'eau
capable de nager sur 200 m sans respirer
xavier a connu une progression
fulgurante champion de france il ya
quelques mois le futur élan courtois
fait ces dernières ondulations dans la
fosse de conflans sainte honorine avancé
second championnat d'europe sous l'eau
le nageur de saint-quentin connaît deux
phases la partie plaisir lors de la cne
statique une sensation d'apesanteur
reposante ce moment où les minutes
souvent trop courtes dans la vie
deviennent alors si longue
mais aussi le côté mental ou l'apnéiste
doit se battre contre son corps et ya
cette deuxième partie qui commence
qu'est ce qu'on appelle la phase de
lutte ou là le corps a envie de respirer
et là c'est complètement l'inversé le
mental qui doit distraire ou doit faire
penser à autre chose qui doit prendre le
pas sur le corps qui a envie de respirer
il est trés dans la tête mais bon il ya
quand même des problèmes de physiologie
parce qu'il ya un problème de
circulation d'oxygène d'eau dans le
corps et il ya des gens qui sont
physiologiquement c'est le cas de xavier
physiologiquement différents doc qui ont
une faculté de mieux gérer l'oxygène
qu'ils ont
l'homme poisson ne se fixe pas de
limites et compte bien monter sur le
podium des prochains championnats
d'europe à antalya en turquie
jusqu'au 2 janvier le 7-8 revient sur
les principaux événements de 2012 qu'il
s'agisse d'économie de culture de
politique ou comme ce soir par exemple
de sport dans un instant à nouvel invité
sur ce plateau pour l'instant c'est vous
qui avait à la parole que peut-on vous
souhaiter pour 2013 de bons résultats du
sérieux en cours depuis de l'amitié une
bonne relation avec mes amis ma famille
santé avant tout beaucoup plus de
justice et que bon il y aura pas trop de
problèmes au niveau économique pour les
gens pour toute la société en fait
qu'on ait une certaine dose de chance
est également surtout la santé quoique
après l'argent ça vient après ensuite
quoi la santé puis plus du travail pour
tout le monde moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que chacun puisse se sentir
soient logés
puis savoir ce qu'il lui faut pour vivre
actuellement c'est pas très bien où on
va mais on aimerait bien que chacun
puisse vraiment être considéré pour une
personne telle qu'elle est
qu'elle puisse avoir des moyens
justement de s'en sortir
le bonheur la sainte et la prospérité la
paix dans le monde
une dizaine de minutes encore à passer
ensemble lors de cette édition du 7 8
toujours le sport à l'honneur anthony
nouvel invité sur le plateau oui notre
second invité philippe pilate au bon
soir à vous vous êtes le directeur de
l'enseignement du golf national
on vous invitez puisque évidemment il ya
la ryder cup qui se profile en 2018 elle
est déjà dans un coin de la tête au golf
national ballet plus que dans un coin
marais de la tête est dans le coin de la
tête de tout le monde en fait cette
ryder cup c'est vrai qu'on attend
tous les collaborateurs du golf national
la fédération le comité ryder cup qui
seront qui sont derrière ce projet tout
à fait oui et alors en 2013 dans les
mois qui viennent il va y avoir des
événements le goal le golf national a
prévu d'encore démocratiser encore un
peu plus ce sport mais la
démocratisation c'est au quotidien de
bancarisation part par le biais
d'opérations
pour sensibiliser à la fois les des
habitants de
guyancourt et également mais tous nos
pères en organise effectivement des
opérations tous les week-ends pour faire
venir un maximum de deux nouveaux
nouveaux joueurs justement la ryder cup
on va peut-être préciser l'importance de
ce que ça représente ce sont les
meilleurs joueurs américains qui
rencontre les meilleurs joueurs
européens dans un tournoi qui existe
depuis 1927 exane heaven et victoire on
est plutôt on est plutôt bien depuis ces
dernières années activement
effectivement et donc au début ils
arrivèrent que pour n'était pas très
bien on a fait rentrer les îles
britanniques
on se rendit 900 sont eux
je n'ai plus l'année en tête je crois
vous aider là vous pouvez pas mais là on
était rentrés effectivement les îles
britanniques et depuis voilà l'europe et
plus tôt et plus tôt devant oui et ça
draine beaucoup beaucoup de monde et
c'est pour ça ce n'est qu'en 2018 en
france mais pour autant dès l'année
prochaine dès 2013 vous allez forcément
continuer à
parler de cet événement pour faire venir
les gens massivement sur saint quentin
en yvelines leur faire comprendre que
c'est important bex est important que
c'était un gros projet c'est vrai que
c'est quand même le troisième événement
qui est le plus suivi derrière les jeux
olympiques et la coupe du monde de
football ce qui n'est ce qui n'est pas
rien ce sont des milliards de
téléspectateurs
en terme de visibilité sur site les sur
les trois jours de tournoi c'est on va
essayer sur le site du loft national de
fer et d'accueillir ce qui sera ce qui
sera le cas en plus de plus de entre 50
et 70 mille spectateurs jours c'est à
peu près 35 mille les jours de
d'entraînement donc c'est vraiment
beaucoup de monde et il ya vraiment une
grosse ferveur et on le voit et on
entend nous de beaucoup de beaucoup de
golfeurs qui nous disent qu'ils sont
déjà sollicités par des étrangers pour
savoir s'ils louent des chambres des
appartements voilà pour pour le public
étranger et la répétition ça qu'est né
c'est l'open de golf qui se déroulera
cette année encore au mois de juillet ça
permet de préparer un petit polar oui
tout à fait selopn traditionnels
évidemment où la majorité des meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux se donnent rendez vous
pour cet open là est ce que vous
préparez déjà la ryder cup par exemple
sur les améliorations qui peut au qu'il
pourrait y avoir sur sur le parcours
notamment le fameux trou numéro 13 qui
qui qui pose pas mal de problèmes mais
effectivement disons que le parcours
c'est une amélioration quotidien sont
des opérations qui font que voilà le
parcours doit être parfait donc à la
fois pour la halle alstom open de france
bien sûr mais également pour pour
l'événement de 2018 donc il ya beaucoup
de travail il ya beaucoup
d'investissements des collaborateurs qui
évoluent sur le terrain et en revenir
aux ou numéro 13 effectivement donc
après bon c'est en effet dans les tuyaux
mais il est de coutume de mettre en
place et de proposer un trou
spectaculaire lors la ryder cup dont il
ya le fameux trou numéro 10 au belfry et
là on va essayer de faire copier cela ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le trou
numéro 13 est un des trous les plus
difficiles du parcours il ya deux jours
un peu partout il ya des bunkers un peu
partout c'est très compliqué là le but
ça serait d'arriver sur le green en un
en fait on a un coût voilà c'est
effectivement donné l'opportunité
l'occasion à un joueur de preneurs et ce
soit le prend le risque de deux voilà de
toucher 2 green en un seul coup sûr ce
par quatre soit de jouer la sécurité et
donc s'y prend le risque de mettre la
pression effectivement sur son
adversaire ce qui peut être voilà sur
les derniers joueurs derniers jours ça
peut ça peut être très très
spectaculaire anthony à une question je
sais que vous mourrez d'envié de la
poser pour savoir si vous donnions il y
aura une grande tête d'affiché qui sera
pleinement de rabais affichés ce que
tiger woods pourrait venir faire des
swings du côté du golf national en
juillet prochain
il est déjà venu d'ailleurs foot il ya
quelques années lorsqu'il était amateur
sur le site du golf national on croise
les doigts pour que tiger woods viennent
sur le site du golf national des
effectifs mais voilà on va tout faire
pour que pour qu'ils soient là un
pronostic peut-être alors pour cet open
de golf qui se déroulera du 4 au 7
juillet à saint quentin en yvelines ces
derniers français c'était 2011 en sait
pas si loin c'était thomas levet du
thomas levet cette année on va souhaiter
un nouveau français pourquoi pas
raphaël jacquelin qui était pas si loin
cette année votre pronostic si vous
vivez on vérifiera ça j'ai bon mois de
juillet merci philippe pilate aude est
revenu sur ce plateau rendez-vous au
golf national donc du 4 au 7 juillet
pour suivre cet open et ces grands
champions peut-être tiger woods en tout
cas tv fil 78 vous en parlera anthony un
dernier sujet à présent pour refermer
cette édition spéciale sport oui on va
aller du côté des rings champion de
france des super moyens en juin dernier
adil hamouma dit le boxeur d'elancourt
avait l'opportunité de combattre pour la
ceinture de champion d'europe face à
l'anglais james degale ancien champion
olympique chez les amateurs en 2008
c'était le combat de sa vie et j'ai pu
suivre sa préparation il ya quelques
semaines
et dire qu'il ya trois ans a dit l'amour
ou mady a failli raccrocher les gants à
32 ans le boxeur élan courtois et face à
son plus grand défi conquérir la
ceinture de champion d'europe des super
moyens mais ce qui l'attend est presque
les vrais ce de sa catégorie le jeune
anglais jay-z galles champion olympique
amateurs à pékin l'an viii ça va être
dans un premier temps pas forcément le
net recul en italie
de gagner de gagner d'entrée avec la
ceinture ça va être ma première envie et
je suis je suis parti pour pour fermer
deux roule si on peut en faire un moment
en emprunts mois lassé du monde de la
boxe amateur il rencontre antoine
farrugia en 2009 à ses côtés le boxeur
il encore toi connaît une ascension
fulgurante des premiers matches de gala
à la victoire en coupe de la ligue
jusqu'au titre de champion de france il
ya quelques mois
tout va très vite pour ce directeur de
centre de loisirs mais il reste les
pieds sur terre
ça reste un plaisir et surtout tant que
ça reste un plaisir à moi je compte
monter temps je me ferait plaisir prime
et
1 m 83 pour 76 kg ce boxeur d'origine
comorienne possède un physique atypique
son envie sa rage de vaincre peuvent
rivaliser avec l'expérience du
britannique vainqueur par ko neuf fois
sur ses 12 victoires
moi je pense que l'autre c'est un garçon
complet au niveau box ville a été
champion olympique comme giuly il est
champion d'europe donc au niveau
technique tactique c'est quelque chose
de formidable mais ce qui ne l'a pas
c'est ce qu'il a dans les points parce
que j'ai des copains enfin des boxeurs
avec qui on va mettre des gants qu'on
travaille il vise il défend ses murs
donc ça veut tout dire comprenez s'il
est capable de défoncer des murs il est
capable de défoncer un goût amer
puisque une simple relation entraîneurs
athlètes un rapport père fils lee addy
lie son coach le duo ne se fixe pas de
limite pour l'instant mais il devra
d'abord franchir l'obstacle anglais pour
continuer de se faire plaisir sur le
réel
malheureusement on va finir un peu
wilfrid sur une note un petit peu moins
heureuse puisque dans la carrière d'un
athlète de haut niveau il n'y a pas que
des victoires et à dia mohammadi a perdu
ce combat pour la ceinture de champion
d'europe au point une défaite très très
serré fin janvier 2013 il remettra à sa
ceinture de champion de france en jeu et
on referme cette édition spéciale sur 70
un petit peu plus triste donc cette
défaite du champion elle le 7-8 est
terminé pour ce soir consacrée aux
événements qui ont marqué l'année 2012
sur le plan sportif vous en savez aussi
un peu plus sur ce qu'ils vont à marquer
2013 merci anthony je vous retrouve
ainsi que l'ensemble de la rédaction dès
le 2 janvier à 18h en direct avec de
nouveau un vie c'est en attendant
l'ensemble de nos éditions spéciales
sont à retrouver sur notre site internet
à très bientôt